اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني
بلينكن انه تحدث مع نظيره الصيني
عبر حسابه على تويتر انه اجرى الليله
مكالمه هاتفيه مع عضو مجلس الدوله ووزير
خارجيه جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
مضيفا انهما ناقش الجهود الجاريه لابقاء
قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه الى جانب قضايا
الثنائيه وعالميه
هذا وقالت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه في بيان
اعرب البلينكن عن اسفه للصعوبات الجديده
التي تعتري العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه
وحمل واشنطن مسؤوليه ذلك وافادت وسائل
الاعلام رسميه ان الوزيره تشين ابلغ نظيره
الامريكي انه يتعين على الولايات المتحده
التوقف عن التدخل في شؤون الصين وقالت
الخارجيه الصينيه انه منذ بدايه العام
الجاري توجه العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه
صعوبات جديده وتحديات وان من يتحمل
مسؤوليه ذلك واضح وفق تعبيره
معنى من بيجي مراسله الجزيره شيماء جو اي
اي شيماء تتحدث عن صعوبات جديده تعتري
العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه ما المقصود
بذلك
من الواضح سهام ان ملف تايوان هو الذي كان
الملف الرئيسي بالنسبه للمحادثات
لتجاره بين الامريكي
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه الصعوبات الجديده
هي كل هذا التوطيط في العلاقات الامريكيه
التايوانيه كل هذا كل هذه العلاقات
الرسميه التي تتم تبادلات رسميه السياسيه
بين واشنطن خلال الاونه الاخيره زياره
الرئيس التايوانيه من خلال الفتره الاخيره
ايضا الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولقاء عليها بكبن مكارسي رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي رغم اعتراض بيجن الشديد وايضا
طلبها من الجانب الامريكي الجانب
التايواني اذا عادم عقد هذا اللقاء هنالك
اتفاقات تجاريه ضخمه اخرها اتفاق تجاري
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين بين واشنطن
تم تسميته باتفاق القرن الحادي والعشرين
سيسمح بازاحه
الاجراءات التي كانت تعيق ربما التجاره
بين واشنطن تجعل التبادلات التجاريه اسهل
بين الجانبين وايضا اتفاقات عسكريه هنالك
ابرام لصفقات بيع اسلحه امريكيه وايضا
حديث كان قد اغضب بيجين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تعتزم خلال
الفتره المقبله ان تقوم بانتاج اسلحتها في
انشاء مصانع للاسلحه الامريكيه في اراضي
الجزيره التايوانيه التي تعتبرها الصين
جزءا من اراضيها المحادثه الهاتفيه بين
تشينغان ووزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكل سهام تاتي في الوقت الذي تقول فيه
مصادر امريكيه بانه خلال اجسام من عشر من
الشهر الجاري سوف يصل وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه في زياره تعتبر الاولى لمسؤول
امريكي رفيع المستوى منذ خمس سنوات الى
الصين فيما لا تريد بيجين ان تعلم او ان
تؤكد صحه هذه الانباء او التنفيها هنالك
ايضا توترات شديده في منطقه بحر جنوب
الصين نتحدث ايضا عن ان هنالك مناورات
عسكريه بحريه واسعه القوات البحريه
الصينيه تمتدي نحو 30 يوما في منطقه بحر
جنوب
الامريكي وايضا لحلفاء الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في المنطقه مثل اليابان الفلبين
وايضا كوريا الجنوبيه بعد ان اتمت واشنطن
وايضا
عسكريه ثلاثيه مشتركه في نفس المنطقه في
منطقه بحر جنوب الصين التي تؤكد بيجن
بانها تحت سيادتها من الواضح بان حديث
حديث تشيكا لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي تحاول
من خلالها الصين اذابه الجديد وايضا رفع
او تعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه التي تشهد
توترا والتدورا خطيرا جدا بحسب تصريحات
الخارجيه الصينيه خلال الاونه الاخيره لكن
الصين تحاول التاكيد للجانب الامريكي بان
المسؤوليه لا
فيما يتعلق بتدهور هذه العلاقات في الاونه
الاخيره هذا ما قاله تشينغان خلال حديثه
مع
هنالك ايضا السهام خلال المحادثه تلميح
الى ملف العلاقات التجاريه الصينيه
الامريكيه وزير الخارجيه الصينيه
بان على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
تتوقف عن تقويض السلام والاستقرار في
العلاقات الصينيه بحجه او ذريعه المنافسه
حديث واضح الى كل العقوبات التي تمزح
تحتها الشركات الصينيه التي تصل اليوم الى
نحو 600 شركه صينيه
مراسله الجزيره كنت معنا من بيجين شكرا لك